foreign
CBS deals and this morning we have
several items that you can use from the
car to the kitchen for the few treats in
between and all an exclusive low prices
to start shopping now scan the QR code
on your screen or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Ashley
Bellman joins us with more good morning
good morning how are you great and I see
you brought back some space yes some of
our favorite so if you watch Shark Tank
this is the number one thing to come out
of the tank this is called drop stop and
this is their best deal yet cbsdeals.com
this one always goes really fast 24.99
is the regular price it is 36 off today
15.99 and you get two so what this does
is this goes over the seat belt catch in
your car it fills that gap between the
driver's seat where everything falls the
black hole I call it the french fries
the phone and you know this is really
going to protect you because 80 of
accidents happen when you take your eyes
off the road for three seconds so this
this is going to stop the phone from
falling stop you from looking away from
the road where you should be looking
it's so effective all the LAPD cars have
these I always lose my glasses I'm
telling you that this I love because
this is the perfect gift it is I'm
wearing it this is Melanie Marie we are
celebrating Black History Month
women-owned black owned company she
creates these beautiful personalized
Jewels she has gold she has silver she
has gold plated rose gold plated I love
it she did all the jewelry for Beyonce's
black is King film so if you are a part
of the Beehive run to cbsdeals.com 30
off today starting at 56 and Wednesdays
really personalize it how you want it it
looks gorgeous I love it so this is 30
off starting at 56 right all right
what's next you know I love clean air I
love to not get sick we don't have time
no one has time to get sick anymore
clean in light air purifiers are
incredible you're saving over a hundred
dollars today can I just say my stylist
was telling me clean it clean light air
clean air in your closet yes gets rid of
moths you would be I mean think of all
the things the Dust In The Air I can now
go to my sister's apartment she has a
cat I have a slight allergy this has
saved the day okay so we have two
options here we have the pro and the XL
the pro is portable you can take it in
the car with you this is 79.99 today up
to 62 percent off this one is
rechargeable so you don't have to have
it plugged in all the time indicator
light so you can see if the air is clean
or not then you have the bigger version
the XL this is 99.99 today and up to 550
square feet is going to purify the air
so great for your house and according to
my stylists well get rid of the mods in
your closet it's incredible and just
knowing that I can take it from my
bedroom to the kitchen easy to move it's
a lot lighter and smaller than most air
purifiers okay I don't know how that
works but that's what she said up to 60
off so glad to have food back in yes yes
okay so these are the only food storage
containers that I'm using from here on
out yes Debbie Meyer green boxes she has
a patented technology that keeps the
food fresh or longer really it's a
no-brainer so for 16.78 40 off today you
know that you don't have to go to the
grocery store as often which you if you
remember I hate to go there and you
don't have to throw out food because
it's going to stay fresh longer 32
different containers different sizes for
your bread for your produce for your
baked goods so many options here and you
can microwave it and put it in the
dishwasher so now is each one 1678 are
you getting us you're getting 32
different containers for 16.70 under 20
and you can have these forever how many
plastic containers can you put in the
microwave and dishwasher not many not
safe how about that these are cats of
course
we partner with all these companies to
get these deals to buy anything you saw
today scan that QR code on your screen
or head on over to cbsdeals.com